about a decade ago I realized that if we
were going to go to Mars with people
would be really expensive and so I
thought to myself what activities have
human cultures engaged in in the past
that were as expensive as what it might
be to go to Mars and what motivated them
to spend that money I was going to fill
a whole book motivations to do great
things great expensive things and then I
find the the tasks I'd find the activity
that morphs most closely resembled what
it would be to go to Mars in the 21st
century I say oh is that what that
culture did with their population is
that how they raise the money if that's
how they convince the people I was gonna
fill a whole book of this it'd be a nice
little reference catalog but how to get
something done in modern times in
conducting that exercise what I found is
that there are only three drivers not
more not less three drivers that account
for the most expensive ambitious
projects humans have ever undertaken one
of them is the praise of deity or
royalty that's what got just got you the
pyramids they're basically expensive
tombstones
so it got the cathedral and church
building of Europe that was a period
where huge fractions of societal
investment went into those activities
there's less of that today so that's not
really a useful driver to think about
how we might transform the 21st century
another driver is war nobody wants to
die that gets you the Great Wall of
China that gets you the Manhattan
Project where we built the bomb that
gets you the Apollo project another
driver the search for economic return
nobody wants to die nobody wants to die
poor the search for economic return
that's what was responsible for the
Columbus voyages the Magellan voyage
Lewis and Clark figuring out what is
beyond that frontier in hugely expensive
enterprises conducted by governments so
if we're going to go to Mars
and if war is not the driver
that you could could easily become the
driver if would be getting on a space
race with someone we view as a military
adversary wonder who that might be
but if peaceful heads prevail then war
is not the driver available to you let's
check our list well kings and gods are
not sufficient in modern times to
undergo heavy projects such as that
what's left the promise of economic
return you can go into space transform
society change the zeitgeist of your
culture turn everyone into people who
embrace and value science technology
engineering and math the STEM fields
whether or not people go into space or
serve the space industry they will have
the sensitivity to those fields
necessary to stimulate unending
innovation in the technology in the
technological fields and is that
innovation in the 21st century that will
drive tomorrow's economies any frontier
in space now involves biologists we're
looking for life chemists geologists
physicists mechanical engineering
Electrical Engineers aerospace engineers
astrophysicists all the traditional
sciences and engineering frontiers are
captured in any ambitious goal to
explore space we can recapture those
times and reinvent America we've already
invented America once before it's ripe
it's ready and it's willing I think to
be invented again
you